[Music]
what's going on guys
Beauty and the Beast it went beast mode
at the box office and you're seeing it
everywhere
buses billboards TV commercials Emma
Watson here they're everywhere and it
got us a nostalgic we did an honest
trailer of 1991 animated film Beauty and
the Beast but one thing that a lot of
people are asking does Belle suffer from
a mental condition known as Stockholm
Syndrome we mentioned it for like two
seconds in the honest trailer and then
you guys wouldn't stop talking about it
so we set out to see if this might be
the case and if any of the other Disney
Princesses suffer from mental condition
enjoy this deep dive into the psychology
of Disney
I'm here with dr. Ramani Durvasula
professor of psychology at Cal State LA
and licensed clinical psychologist yeah
thanks for sitting down with us thanks
for having me one of the main
contentions about Beauty and the Beast
is that Belle suffers from Stockholm
Syndrome the whole idea of Stockholm
Syndrome has actually been debunked in
the literature so this idea of one
falling in love with a captor that that
entire phenomenology has sort of been
left by the wayside what we do though
have is a dynamic that concerns me
because he is in fact her captor he is
abusive he is sort of always yelling and
running around the castle being quite a
little grumpy beast and she falls in
love with him this idea that her love
can rescue him from his anger that's one
of the reasons I've always had so much
trouble with Beauty and the Beast
however it's ironic that from the mouths
of babes
it was my 13 year old daughter with it I
think you're being too harsh mom because
I really think it's a movie about maybe
not judging a book by it's cover I
understand what she's saying and she
said mom yeah big hairy ugly guy can
find love he had a big hairy ugly but
here's the problem a big hairy ugly guy
and fall in love with him and then he
still turned into sort of your
garden-variety handsome prince yeah if
it really was that kind of I love him no
matter what he would have stayed big
Harry oh god help Shrek now so let me
ask them what would you diagnose the
East with I mean the beef definitely
feels like a narcissist until he's not
right then he becomes a sweetheart and
he starts being a loving guy my concern
there is that within many narcissistic
relationships people keep waiting for
the narcissist to turn around and become
a sweetheart so that never happens in
real yeah I can fix him anything sir
trust me if I can't with all my big guns
you can't either
may I posit one more potential diagnosis
for Belle okay
schizophrenia because she sees
candlesticks and silverware coming to
life we're substance abuse she could
have been using LSD yeah if you've been
using MDMA yeah I mean you know which
mentor in the beach might have had
better sad what is it
but right let's talk Gaston I guess Don
a bit of a bully
it keeps compensating for something
what's the root of his severe narcissism
all bullies are compensating for
something
keep that in mind there's no need to be
a bully unless you feel like there's
something lacking right why do you need
to go around sort of bouncing around in
fact wasn't he more of a beast than the
beast and he was the handed him guide
and that something lacking could be
either like oh I don't like the size of
mine or I was never good enough to
satisfy daddy exactly that's usually
what it is it is those daddy issues or
mommy issues but I am not good enough so
when you feel like you're not good
enough and you feel that empty inside
you're always overcompensating with the
sort of grandiose entitled personality
I'd love to shift gears and talk about
Sleeping Beauty and Snow White is a
desire to kiss sleeping people normal
problematic some kind of psychosis
that's a real problem for me with Snow
White in fact I got to tell you snow
white ooh the close second to beauty and
the beach for a story that I really
malign and sort of the entire Disney
pantheon so what's that as a dating
guide fall asleep and you'll meet the
man of your dreams yeah also is just
teaching our young men to go around and
kiss sleeping women hmm not okay I'd
like to talk about Peter Pan and his
titular syndrome yes I just wanted to
say the word titular what is Peter Pan
syndrome and does Peter Pan suffer from
it well Peter Pan syndrome is the idea
of the man who wants
stay forever a child in every way you
know which which I thought was in fact
all men vital there's something
moderately creepy about it cuz like
really child is like they still have
action figures in their package at home
like that sort of fetus I'm hoping that
several personal criticism let me ask
you this day drinking Peter Pan syndrome
day drinking may actually be alcoholism
okay moving on I'd like to talk about
the movie Aladdin classic yeah Genie
Robin Williams classic classic he spends
thousands of years locked alone in a
lamp
what kind of trauma would that long-term
isolation caused and does the genie show
any signs of trauma solitary confinement
is actually one as a premier form of
torture and in fact it is a to a
punishment using prison systems and in
military systems but it's interesting
when the genie gets released she's quite
manic right he's talking very quickly
exactly there's this real mania about
the genie and so it does make you wonder
how you know maybe that that's also one
of the symptoms - like if his thoughts
are racing his pressured speech one of
the symptoms of mania we specially
inReach pressured speeches when you're
talking very quickly sometimes not
making sense and no one else can get a
word in edgewise one of those sites no
substitutions exchanges every time dr.
Davila
let's talk about stabled story Pinocchio
ah yes he clearly shows signs of being a
pathological liar what underlying
beneath the surface
given that Pinocchio was a child
pathological lying can be associated
with things like we call conduct
disorder conduct disorder is often sort
of the the chapter one you know sort of
the preface to what we call antisocial
personality disorder which is often
popularly termed psychopathy or being a
psychopath
Benigno Freud would have had a field day
with Pinocchio sometimes which are just
a cigar sometime the nose is just a nose
oh okay
so Pinocchio's nose growing is like a
wish fulfillment for us and it's a whole
edible thing yeah I get what I'm doing I
try neither whistle I'm talking about a
penis okay where you could just say
penis - oh no I would never say penis
I'm not going to say penis I say it a
lot of the whistle
whistles let us venture under the sea if
you will let's do it and talk about the
Little Mermaid Ariel shows clear signs
of hoarding and wondering is this
symptomatic of something else why does
one hoard it seems more like she's a
collector than a you know kids
love to collect stuff that's not an
uncommon and I got havior like a kid
kids children not grown men
I mean jellies Arthur's I mean they're
not toys they're collectibles you can
call them whatever you want that will a
grown man with an action figure yeah
okay okay so I think that you know Ariel
and all her collecting that is a very
child childlike pursuit and she's child
in some ways in essence but she's it's
all so coveted I mean she sort of covets
this other place so it's almost like
somebody I don't know collecting
whatever things from another part of the
world that they want to travel to that's
what it sort of feels like there's
something poignant about it rather than
her being sort of a person who collects
like his like raccoons walking through
her house or something she longs to be
up on the land where the people all
right how how does someone go about
integrating into society having never
met a human being it's a really good
question in some ways Ariel story is an
immigrant's tale isn't it it is very
difficult to integrate into a new world
and you know and to get your voice in
your legs and in essence those are
interesting metaphors and that so
definitely what it's about
it's not easy ask anyone who's moved to
a new country especially one where they
don't speak the language and she was
remember she was rendered silent when
she first came to land because her voice
was taken away so she couldn't see she
couldn't communicate in her new land so
I really do think that that's very
difficult to do let's talk about Walt
Disney I wonder what it says about him
that so many of the Disney films
involved dead parents yeah
mm-hmm I keep in mind the loss of a
parent I actually don't know enough
about Walt Disney's own early history to
wonder if what kinds of parental issues
he had but it does make me wonder if
there was some sort of separation or
loss that was sticking with him for that
theme to come up those are the stories
he chose because in these early news
dad went out to get a pack of smokes in
there never came back I don't know but
there's something going on there yeah
yeah it is yes it is now let me ask you
this does Disney give young girls
unhealthy notions of what it means to
grow into a woman I do worry that it
does because although Disney started
getting a little bit more progressive
and we're seeing more progressive sort
of princess type figures Melana is a
great example one of my favorite
princess because she's a leader
she's heroic and she doesn't have a love
interest in almost every other disease
film even the lawn which features a
warrior there's still a guy there still
you know a love guy Disney films filled
with classic villains not that on some
of them probably have psychological
issues I think most of them villains
always have psychological issues that's
why they're going I'm going to name a
villain and I would love it if you could
give us a simple diagnosis Cruella De
Vil
101 Dalmatians that psychopathic to
murder all those dogs to make a coke and
she wanted to keep killing them I don't
think any piece of clothing is ever
worth harming a defenseless creature for
that's true from Aladdin Jafar Jafar
again a psychopath still pinned in
general our psychopath
but in his case he had a absolutely
focused obsession with power so there's
a real obsessional piece scar from the
lion I mean there's another psychopath
and he's a murderer yeah look I mean
Cruella de Vil murderer - she killed all
those dogs but scar killed his own
brother
that's fratricide Ursula Oh or salami or
Salah covets that covetousness is very
much not only a part of narcissism but
also again being a psychopath and Ursula
doesn't feel bad about taking Ariel's
voice again it's the lack of remorse in
all of these villains that comes back
narcissus sometimes feel bad when they
do bad things like you but Psychopaths
don't feel bad they just do bad things
and then they just go home and eat a
pizza and they're fine with it
did you just call the endorsers I hinted
we may need to talk and there's still
that action-figure problem
giving appointment times open for a
leader I'm pretty full up for the next
few weeks but I bet we can get you in
next month okay dr. Ramani Durvasula
thank you for diagnosing these Disney
Princesses I feel like we've learned a
lot and I unexpectedly learned more
about myself than I wanted to sounds
like a win thank you thank you doctor
well that was fun
I want to say thanks again to dr.
diverse Allah for putting up with our
shenanigans but I am still wondering
what that Peter Pan syndrome thing is
I'm grown man by the way guys we want to
hear from you we want to answer your
questions in an upcoming segments that
we call steer screen junkies what kinds
of questions all kinds of questions
stuff about movies stuff not about
movies just about life marital advice
favorite pizza toppings who knows I may
regret saying this but anything goes
check out the description below for how
to contact us and then send us your
question I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
hey guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more